Hello I’m allegedly Andrew Heaton
and you’re watching fake news Mostly Weekly
This week this internet is abuzz with talk
about Roy Moore.
In fact I believe we have footage of some
of the public's reactions?
Masks of the indicated sizes are chosen and
fitted-
Republican Roy Moore is gunning for the U.S.
senate seat in Alabama.
A seat still sticky from where Jeff Sessions
hid his hard candy.
So far nine women have come forward to accuse
Moore of sexual misconduct,
several of whom were minors at the time.
If he’d been convicted,
Moore could have faced a prison sentence of
up to 10 years.
Which may not be the first time
Moore has exposed himself to something of
up to 10 years.
Hey-O!
Roy Moore has so far denied all the allegations
though he has suggested he would be happy
to spend some time in Juvie.
Really? Alright.
I’m not here to tell you whether Moore is
guilty or not.
But I can tell you that Roy Moore is guilty
of molesting-
our freedom.
He’s diddling our democracy.
And he’s inviting rule-of-law up to his
hotel room for a massage and a movie deal.
So here are 13 non-pedophile reasons why you
can hate Roy Moore:
He’s a terrible judge.
On two separate occasions, the Alabama’s
Court of Judiciary
unanimously defrocked Moore.
At last, the defrocker has become the defrockee!
The Court deemed Moore "grossly inconsistent
with his duties"
and "incomplete, misleading, and manipulative"
in their unanimous vote to defrock him.
Unanimous!
Courts are never unanimous.
The Supreme Court wasn’t even unanimous
about whether or not to legalize butt stuff.
Roy Moore is a terrible judge because he doesn’t
actually believe in upholding the law
unless he personally agrees with it.
Being a judge who refuses to uphold laws is
like being a birdwatcher who refuses to watch birds.
What is the point of you?!
Moore thinks the Bible supersedes the Constitution,
and that God is "the only source of our law,
liberty, and government."
So let’s say we ghost the founding fathers,
burn the constitution, and say ‘screw it’
to a 200 year-old consensus and we decide
to merge the church and state.
Well whose church?
It’s not like there’s, I dunno, 8,000
different protestant denominations
with their own interpretations of the Bible.
And look, I’m not anti-religion.
I love christianity.
I love what ya did with Western Civilization.
It's terrific.
But we have separation of church and state
for good reason.
The first time Moore got defrocked
it was for unveiling a five ton Ten Commandments
monument
inside the State Judicial Building.
In 2005 he authored the Constitution Restoration
Act,
which would empower Congress to remove any
judges who failed to uphold God's law.
You know who else thinks that God is the only
source of law?
That cab driver.
Moore is so untied to reality or facts
that he believes that Sharia law governs parts
of the country.
According to Moore:
"There are communities under Sharia law right
now in our country.
Up in Illinois.
... There’s Sharia law, as I understand
it, in Illinois, Indiana -- up there.”
When asked how he knew, he said.
“I was informed.”
because that’s what we want in a judge:
no concern for reality.
And I don’t know what Moore’s complaining
about
when his principles overlap with radical islam
quite nicely.
Moore is a homophobe.
Moore described homosexuality as "abhorrent,
immoral, detestable, a crime against nature,"
You’d think for a guy with with such a penchant
for leather vests,
he'd be more open to the gays.
Moore not only defied the Supreme Court’s
2015 ruling on Gay Marriage,
he instructed Alabama’s probate judges to
do the same.
Roy Moore is quoted as saying
“'Maybe Putin is right with his opposition
to gay marriage.”
Quick note- When you start a sentence with
“Maybe Putin is right” you’re wrong.
Unless that sentence ends with “about to
drop a sick beat.
Hit it!”
And to round it out here’s a quick list
of other reasons Roy Moore is a human hpv virus:
He taught a class discouraging women from
running for office
He’s referred to people as “reds and yellows”
He thinks the pedophilia accusations are pushed
by homosexuals and socialists.
Accepted money from a Neo-nazi group.
Said gay marriage was worse than slavery.
Wouldn’t rule out death penalty for gays.
Wants to rescind free trade agreements.
Anti-immigrant.
Believes Obama wasn’t born in America.
Believes 9/11 is God's punishment for legalizing
sodomy and abortion.
So, in summation,
Roy “want-some-candy” Moore
is pretty much the closest thing we have to
an American Taliban.
And finally, if all those reasons weren’t
enough
to convince you that Roy Moore is petty tyrant
and therefore a bad person:
there’s no way he’s not a pedo-